hey everyone I'm Ramona and this is Huda
we're both designers and practicing
design thinkers at IBM Watson in data
analytics in this Workshop will be
showing you why design thinking is
essential in creating impactful products
especially in open-source
space just to give you some background
about us part of our values as designers
is advocating for design and its users a
lot of times users have no choice and
they're stuck working with applications
that are not very intuitive or easy to
use making their tasks more difficult
I've worked on products that were
designed by developers and they were
catering to the ease of building the
application versus building it so that
it's easy for the user so when
applications are being built designers
have a responsibility to advocate for
the users and really investigate and
explore how we can build a design for
them the
user so when Huda and I both learned
about open source it sounded like a
magical place where anyone in the world
could contribute and maintain software
free freely it made sense you're
building for people by the people right
but reality is that sometimes software
doesn't look so magical so many
open-source softwares uh are made with
little or no contribution from a
professional designer which leads to
hardto ous
interfaces uh there are thousands of
cool open- Source projects that are po
poorly designed and limits who can use
them so you might ask yourself why
aren't designing designers contributing
to them that's a really good question
like complicated softwares open source
can be a bit overwhelming for
non-technical people so open source
itself isn't designed for designers it's
Dev Centric so it's pretty intimidating
for people like us like
designers so Our intention today is to
help equip you with the right design
tools to sprinkle into your open-source
contributions and also advocate for
design
so let's dive into a scenario where
designthinking tools could help us solve
a real world challenge right now IBM is
currently working on a Linux Foundation
project designed to help farmers in
India effectively Harvest their crops
and conserve resources like water these
farmers are presented with daily
challenges like not having stable access
to Wi-Fi limitations and being able to
read and write among other barriers this
is a real life scenario that affects
people globally at IBM we're in the
middle of Designing and proposing a
better solution for
it and keep in mind the end Solutions
are not always perfect part of the
design journey is always iterating and
improving design to always be better
than the previous
version So based on this project we
wanted to recreate this scenario with
everyone and see what we can come up
with in this one-hour
Workshop so let's start with a scenario
imagine you're stationed in India you've
been been asked to improve the way
Farmers Farm currently India supports
15% of the world's population but only
has 4% of the world's Water Resource
this is super concerning right now
because majority of farming totally
depends on the
rain so imagine in this scenario you've
been tasked to develop a solution to
help farmers water their crops
efficiently what would be the first step
in your development process
please use the Discord thread to submit
your
response you have two
[Music]
minutes
l
[Music]
okay awesome let's take a look at some
of the
comments okay it looks like we have one
comment sorry it's being blocked by
my okay so talking to Farmers that is a
great response um and it actually goes
into um one of our first
lessons um which is yes
uh the answer is yes empathizing with
your user this is usually the first step
that we take when we're design thinking
so awesome job uh you just unlocked your
first lesson and you did it correctly so
whenever you receive a problem always
think about your users and what they're
going
through so you're may be thinking what
is design thinking really simply design
thinking is a philosophy and a set of
tools to help you solve problems
creatively when a company is trying to
create something new when a team is
trying to solve a complex problem you
can use design thinking to help you get
to that
solution so design thinking specifically
focuses on the human centered design
aspect of problem solving it's a human
centered approach that focuses on
empathizing figuring out who you're
designing for what their needs are and
then helping solve that problem or need
a lot of our problem solving techniques
before design thinking was about well we
have this technology let's just use it
to build it for someone uh design
thinking specifically helps you think
about the problem from the customer or
user's perspective and in this example
if I put myself in the farmer shoes I
would wish that there was a cheap and
easy way to know when to water my
crops so there there are five steps to
every design thinking process one
empathizing with your users two defining
the problem three ideating a solution
four rapid prototyping and five testing
out prototype today we'll be focusing on
the first
three and for these next lessons we'll
be guiding you through most of the
activities using the farmer scenar
scario as our Focus so as designers when
dealing with problems like this our
first step is to normally set up an
interview with our users and take notes
on what our users are doing thinking and
feeling and the intention is to record
our users everyday paints and to
advocate for them throughout the entire
development process so we can practice
this together I'm going to hand it off
to Huda to kick us
off thanks Ramona so our first activity
will consist of us doing an empathy map
um so what is an empathy map this is a
tool a team will use to help understand
their users or customers on a deeper
level an empathy map can represent a
group of users or a customer segment and
an organization can have multiple
customer segments or personas they focus
on and they can build out multiple
empathy maps for each Persona or
customer
segment empathy maps are important
because it helps us identify users pain
points potential gaps and opportunities
as well as better understand the end
user this is usually a collaborative
activity so by the end of it we can
align with all of our stakeholders on a
shared understanding of the user or
customer segment as well as their
various pain points this helps us
prioritize which opportunities of the
user Journey we should focus on many
times ux designers carry a
responsibility to advocate for those
design for those users and as well as
innovate on behalf of their end users
but to do that we need a deeper
understanding of the end user empathy
Maps they're a good start to do that we
focus on what the customer is thinking
feeling seeing hearing seeing and
doing so let's try this together so if
everyone can visit the Google Drive Link
and open the empathy map that was
provided um you can either create a copy
of it or download it and print it and
work off of that
one you can start to take notes in each
of those categories and section
and you can take a picture or a
screenshot and post it on the Discord
Channel when you're ready um you can
base your responses uh based on a
recording that will play shortly and I'm
just going to give you a couple minutes
to first get the downloads so normally
we would do this activity all together
in one place but just um due to some
limitations we have technically we're
going to do it individually and just
share our
responses all right I think we can go to
the next
activity so for this project we've sent
out a couple of user researchers to
India to learn more about the farmers
day-to-day life and their situation it's
important that you listen to this since
it would create a foundation for the
next
activities so here's a two-minute
recording of their conversation listen
carefully and take notes on the empathy
map when you hear cues about what the
farmer's feeling and what what they're
thinking and also doing we couldn't
share the true recording of this so this
is a mock version uh by the way if you
aren't able to access the empathy map uh
feel free to just take a piece of paper
and write down uh what you think that
person just like making notes while
you're going while we're playing the
recording for
yall hi Arjun could you introduce
yourself and tell us a bit about your
background I'm 26 years old I have a
wife and four children
I am a farmer in my Village of cartica
India did you go to
school I went to elementary school and
started reading and writing but now
sometimes I I feel like I struggle to
read and write what do you do on a usual
day on the farm I wake up turn on the TV
or radio to listen to the weather
forecast if they say it'll rain this
week I won't water my crops instead I'll
collect rain water in my well for later
if it says there is no rain I collect
rainwater from the pond nearby or I will
pump water from the well to water our
crops depending on the schedule and
weather I plan my daily activities like
watering or harvesting my plants what
makes your job
challenging water India's weather is
extremely dry I am feeling very worried
and stressed
that my farm hardly has any water and my
crops are in danger I'm always confused
when to water my plants because the
weather is so unreliable some days it
rains most days it doesn't I also don't
know how much water I should give to my
different crops I am running out of
water now and my crops are slowly dying
what are you currently doing to resolve
this
problem everything I learn about the
weather from the TV or radio station
I ask my elders because they have lots
of experience but they say the weather
has changed nothing is helping I am
always thinking should I water today or
save the water for later it's not easy
do you have a phone what do you use it
for our family has a cheap Android phone
we don't use it that much we only use it
to take some photos or call a friend we
also use it for a local banking app I
get most of my information from our
radio
station do you use any farming
technology I have heard about new
farming technologies that provide crop
and watering advice but these are very
complex and expensive products which are
not affordable for me those are all my
questions thank you for your time Arjun
you are
welcome cool so to Huda sorry go for it
Huda thanks I was just going to say so
now that you've heard the recording and
have a better sense of the farmer's
challenges um let's take three minutes
to finish filling out the empathy map
try to identify any fears obstacles or
frustrations the farmer might be having
as well as their wants hopes and dreams
and identifying what their pains and
gains
are so go ahead and add in your points
and make notes if you see any emerging
patterns
here
[Music]
e
so two minutes left um remember to try
to put yourself in the farmer shoes and
understand what they're experiencing and
feeling in the situation if you've
already filled out the empathy map
please post some screenshots or photos
in the Discord
[Music]
thread
I
[Music]
so time's up um sorry let me just double
check I think there's one more minute
right Ron yeah there's one more minute
one more minute I see one resp response
please people um post any responses you
can you
think
[Music]
doing
I
[Music]
cool time's up okay so it seems like we
we got a a lot of responses so that's
great thanks y'all I'm going to switch
over to Discord um Conrad if you're on
the call are a are people able to go off
mute and describe uh what they've
posted um I think we would have to
invite them on so it wouldn't be an easy
process okay that's fine we're going to
randomly choose
somebody's okay Stony
95 so it looks like for says uh the
farmer has a wife four children learn to
read and write but struggles at the
moment relies on TV and radio for the
weather forecast has a phone in the
family digital farming products are
expensive that's great thinks does not
know how much water should be given to
the
plants does listen to the radio for the
weather forecast depending on what he
decides to either uh do water plants or
collect water he feels that water is
limited and stressed and in
danger great great work
guys looks like we have a lot of great
responses
here so I'm going to keep
going
so as you can see um right now the
farmer we did this activity as well but
uh it's pretty in line with what your
response is the farmers feeling
frustrated uh because they don't know
when they'll have water for their crops
they feel fear due to the unreliability
of the weather and uh success of the
harvesting the crops they're seeing
uncertainty and hearing the news on the
radio is not necessary neily reliable
and regardless of all that they continue
to farm and sometimes potentially waste
resources and they're running out of
water okay so moving
on so our next activity is creating an
AIS scenario map so what is an AIS
scenario map this is another framework
that designers use to map and document
our understanding of the current user
experience we build out the current
journey to identify the problem and
opportunities to see if we're focusing
on the right improvements when there is
a new project to deliver it's important
for our team to align on what they
already know and note what they don't
know we can take some of our findings
from the empathy map and plug them into
our Asis scenario
map so for this activity you can find
the Asis scenario map document in the
Google drive as well you can also either
create a copy of it or download the file
and work off of that you can also use
paper and pencil um and try to fill let
in afterwards you can similarly to the
last activity post a photo on the
Discord thread uh and now you can just
take a couple minutes to open up your
scenario
map so in the scenario map we have four
rows labeled phases doing thinking and
feeling with this we'll basically map
out the current user journey in the
perspective of the
farmer so start with listing out what
the farmer is doing thinking and feeling
and then add f phases as they become
clear for some examples um some examples
of phases might be they're planning
their day they're watering their crops
their spring or harvesting crops and so
on so take four minutes to add in your
points um take a screenshot or photo and
you can paste in your AIS scenario map
into the Discord Channel when you're
done try to look for any patterns
emerging or similar themes for each
phase an activity so I'm going to we're
going to start the timer now and give
you four minutes for
[Music]
this
he
[Music]
okay we have three more minutes
left
[Music]
okay we have one more minute
left
[Music]
e
awesome so let's review the Asis
scenario that we've created I'm going to
give you guys a minute just to finish
pasting them into the slack thread and
then we'll go through them
together so these are Frameworks that we
actually use in our day-to-day uh job um
they're accessible under IBM's website
under like I can post the link later
it's part of the design IBM thinking um
toolkit and they have like a various
amount of of different Frameworks or or
templates that you guys can follow
similar to this we've just created our
own
variation so let's take a look at the
Discord really quick
I'm going to scroll down and thank you
for
posting okay phases get information
decide on activities water
crops uh collect water so for doing the
farmer is listening to the radio checks
the weather on the phone checks the
crops Health the water reservoir what
the farmer is thinking they're
considering the state of the crop um and
the state of the water what Reservoir
they consider the crop Health crop
weather
forecast um when they're actually
watering their crop they're thinking
should I water my crops today and then
when they're actually collecting water
they're thinking if they should be
collecting water so this uncertainty uh
really puts a lot of pressure on the
farmer and uh makes them rely on their
intuition a lot which may not be uh the
best uh thing to rely on uh for for
things that are out of their
control but they're feeling um so
they're just unsure about what to do
with their crops and they hope that
water will
be this water will be useful soon this
is great uh thank you so much for for
posting this uh we really appreciate it
we've also created our own um which is
really similar to the one that was just
read I'm going to Huda uh take a stab at
it
though uh sure okay so just to um walk
through this one as well so the phase
that we defined in this one is checking
the weather and planning their day um
and then they would go and try to manage
their resources and then they would tend
to their crops and then finally they
would Harvest their crops um so it's
just a little bit different than what we
just went over in the other example um
so yeah what they're doing this one's
pretty similar they're listening to the
radio checking the TV for weather um
collecting their water if rainfalls in
the well or pumping water um from the
pond to water their crops um and then
they're also picking weeds spraying
pesti pesticides and doing farming
activities like that and then they're
also picking crops and selling them so
it's a little bit different if you can
see from the other responses as well
which is okay like one exam one thing
here is um a lot of people will have
perfectly correct responses but you
might not think of all the different
scenarios um so now if you go over these
two scenarios you have a more clear view
of this Asis journey and you can see how
they're you know doing uh and feeling
during each of the activities on this
journey um but just looking at these two
maps that are that we went over you can
see there's two different perspectives
here um some ideas are similar and
there's also some New Perspective added
as well well so normally we do do this
collaboratively and we try to refine it
in a manner that we can align on because
we can't always tackle every part of the
scenario um and we try to decide on like
okay this is the section we're actually
going to focus on so in this case we can
see some opportunities opportunities
here um the opportunities here could be
being able to provide more reliable
information with or without stable
internet access being able to simplify
language and maybe using visual language
um and by centralizing all sources of
information on the weather forecast um
as well as yeah using easier
vocabulary um are not using vocabulary
vocabulary at all and just using visual
communication with people who have
trouble reading or using technology also
we can learn to understand growth stages
to see how much water is required per
stage trying to provide smart
accommodations so I guess we can move on
to the next activity here so based on
everything we've learned in the last two
activities um let's start our next
activity which is ideation so now that
we've identified the current scenario
and understand the gaps problems and
opportunities let's ideate on a few Sol
few Solutions so in this activity we
want to hear everyone's unique
perspective on the user and the problem
so everyone should contribute their
ideas and solutions so for this activity
we want to start off going to the
Discord Channel and write in the thread
some possible solutions in a couple
words or short sentences so let me just
paste the thing for the Discord
Channel and this way we can go over
everyone's replies so this is like a
very brief solutioning stage of let's
have a big picture A big idea of what we
think the solution might look like so
you know based on everything you've
heard um go to the the Discord Channel
and can you think of a solution right
off the bat that we can try to implement
to help solve this
problem thanks UD I'm going to set the
timer for two
[Music]
minutes
also sorry we're at the one minute Mark
so one minute left uh but I just wanted
to add don't think about the feasibility
on how how feasible this solution might
be or even consider how we can make this
done just shoot through the moon and
focus on the biggest ideas and try to
build off of each other's ideas as well
because I see some people are typing um
if you see another idea and you feel
like you want to jump off of it that's
totally fine as
well so avoid talking about
implementation or any those types of
details just talk about the solution
idea that you
have
pleas
[Music]
a
I'm going to stop the timer it looks
like we have a lot of responses so than
thanks
everyone I'm going to ask everyone as
the to read through some of the
responses and put a thumbs up on the
ones that they like and then uh we'll
start reading them out loud in in the
meantime yeah so this is basically like
voting so what we want to give everyone
five votes and to vote just put a thumbs
up on any of the ideas that people
posted of the ones that you think are
the best for this
HUD I'm just going to read some out loud
because these are really awesome sure
okay so better weather forecast sent to
their mobile that makes sense uh
hydrogen fueled electrical generators
the water that otherwise is a waste
could be used for
irrigation that's a very good
idea getting in contact with government
bodies and NOS in the area forming a
local community with other Farmers I
love that that's like a great
crowdsourcing technique too they can
share all their information together um
there are they did mention that there
are farmers who can intu intuitively uh
know that when the rain is falling so
maybe they can share their knowledge
that
way um creating an Android app that
recommends the optimal action collect
water uh water plants but also expl
explains the recommendation in terms of
the domain the precipitation drout
storage crop growth with pictograms that
is a great idea um and uh seems in line
with some of what we were thinking U
which we'll show later
on person has access to a phone perhaps
an app where the user can input track
their water reserves and crop Health
types of crops and the app can can use
weather forecast to help them give
sample suggestions like use water
reserves today or collect rain today
might be helpful yes this seems really
in line with uh the previous response so
amazing more education information uh
correct irrigation volume for each crop
that's a great answer as
well okay so I see people are starting
to
vote
we're going to go back to the
presentation
okay um so it looks like the the
top
um yeah the top voted ones were the the
second last one and the third last one
so thanks yall um this is a really good
uh trans transition to to what we were
thinking as
well so I'm going to give it back to you
Huda to to close us off with our 2B
Journey sure thank you so let's see how
we can incorporate these Solutions into
the future journey of our far farmer so
you know we could use this one that says
person has access to a phone perhaps an
app where the user can input t or track
their water reserves and crop health for
the types of crops and the app can use
weather for cast to help them give
Simple Solutions like use water reserves
today collect rainwater uh might be
helpful so that one got the most B so we
can do something like that to see how we
can incorporate this into the future
journey of our farmer um so the next
activity here is the 2B scenario so
after an ideation session we normally do
this activity um where we create the 2B
scenario map 2B scenario Maps help us
Envision and align on a better future
for our users now that we have created
an as a scenario Ario map and have also
come up with some ideas and solutions we
need to see how they fit in into an
user's future Journey do they still make
sense and actually improve the user
Journey um a 2B scenario map is a great
framework to share with stakeholders to
show how your design intent and over and
get the overall team aligned it also
helps tell a more engaging story on what
the team is envisioning so just as an
example you can see here on the slide
the outcome of the 2B scenario map we
did in this activity um let me hand it
back to Ramona to share more on
that sorry y'all we're having a bit of
technical problems here that's okay
that's while you get that up um yeah so
this this can also be used a way to like
really sell an idea um sometimes you
know you might not get buyin but when
you do all of these activities you can
get better um feedback from the team as
well as get Buy in from the team to
actually propose these Solutions and
actually work on them because just
because you always have a good idea
doesn't mean you get to work on it
right yeah so when our team and IBM did
this activity they proposed the idea of
an app so we know that our Farmers
usually have access to a phone so a
mobile app is a viable option the idea
is that we're we're thinking of creating
an Android app that would give farmers
accurate weather forecast and track the
moisture level of their soil so during
the ideation and research phase the team
found that the farmers can optimize
their water usage by knowing exactly how
much the water how much water each crop
would need so um a berry plant doesn't
need the same amount of water as a corn
plant and each plant requires different
water consumptions so the app would
essentially sink up with an affordable
soil Mo soil moisture reader that
prevents the farmers from overwatering
their plants um so we have added the 2B
Journey map handout in in that kit or on
the Google link Google Drive Link so if
you would like to try it out after the
workshop please feel free
to so after the 2B scenario we enter
into our favorite stage prototyping and
testing when when we prototype the goal
is to rapidly test and validate our
ideas we want to see if our assumptions
are true in a cheap and easy way so for
this project the team did a paper
prototype we tried to simulate what each
screen would look like in our app and
then test it out with our users it was
really important uh at this phase to
listen and watch for Behavioral cues so
if if we did find that the user is
surprised or does something unexpected
when they're using our prototype um we
would note it down and iterate on the
solution and then come back and test it
again so for this project the team did
around four to five iterations and once
we were confident with the Prototype we
started
building so let's go through the
solution that IBM team built I'll start
with the
scenario so imagine it's a scorching hot
last few days and arjin the farmer hopes
that rain will come soon he hardly has
water and his crops are in danger the
weather forecast for his City is given
through the radio and the chance of rain
is really low but he's unsure if he
should spare his water or he should hold
out uh a bit longer for the
raid so through local event arjent
learns about liquid prep an app that
provides realtime guidance on water for
Farmers a soil sensor is required to
detect the temperature of the soil
humidity so he purchases the sensor from
the event and he downloads the app as
soon as he gets
home so arent opens up this app and goes
through the onboarding experience each
slide is accompanied by an audio
instruction and it gives Argin an
overview about how liquid Prep Prep
works so after going through the
onboarding experience arjent sees that
the weather
information um he sees the weather
information is prompted to enter his
crop and he's pleased to see upto-date
weather information since he only get
get weather information from the
newspapers TV or radio and sometimes his
his
neighbor now he can check the weather
any time that he
wants and uh when he clicks to select
his crop he can easily and accurately
select his type of crop by taking a
photo of it or just saying the name he
is also prompted to select the stage of
growth um and and within the step it was
really important since the app would
give him uh
some type of guidance on how much he
should water his plants at each stage of
growth since the solution involved an
iot a soil sensor he is shown visually
uh a visual tutorial on how to set it
up and after a few seconds arjin
receives information for water
recommendation and he sees that he
should wait 3 days before using any
water because the rain is expected soon
so he can easily read the instructions
using using these the visual
Legend um of course this is a happy path
but uh we do have confidence in our app
so he does follow the advice and
successfully saves water and his crops
are growing
again so great work uh you made it
you've done the four new you have
exercised the four new design thinking
steps um um remember when we first asked
you at the beginning of the workshop
what would be your first step in the
development process um this time you
guys will say empathy math um so again
uh design thinking is a human centered
approach for uh problem solving and it
makes it makes just these types of
activities a lot more user
Centric
so again you guys have learned four new
steps to incorporate in your velopment
process you have your empathy map where
you're learning about what your users's
thinking feeling and doing your AIS
Journey map um these are again the steps
that the user needs needs to take in
order to accomplish a goal ideate
ideating those solutions to alleviate
your user's pain points and then your 2B
Journey mapping which uh is the journey
that your user will be taking with your
new
solution so open source is a space made
for Innovation it's a really special
place that we can turn a simple idea
into a working product that anyone can
use and you guys made the first step in
helping make the software even more user
friendly by just learning about and
learning and thinking about your user so
thank you very very much um we really
hope that you guys took away some stuff
from this workshop and you could you
utilize it in your development process
again thank you so much for
participating and actively sharing your
ideas um if you guys would like to uh
contribute to this to a project similar
to this in the future um Huda and I just
created this form really quick uh so you
guys can input your information and we
would be really happy to connect you to
the right people at IBM um if you did
choose to uh if you wanted to contribute
to to similar
projects we would also love to hear what
y'all felt about this presentation did
you learn did you walk away learning
something new we'd love to hear it uh
please feel free to uh add us on
LinkedIn or just DM us about your
feedback or um how you would like to
join our open source Community thanks
all I hope you have a great rest of your
day